[Applause]
so the other day i was in the kitchen
in my house and wendy was watching a
movie in in the living room
and for the life of me i could not i
know i knew i'd seen the movie before
but for the life of me i couldn't
remember
what it was um i even recognized the
actors voices and stuff
and so i sat there for like five minutes
just listening to it
trying to trying to remember what it was
and
eventually i went in there because i
just broke and she was watching the
notebook which is
ah yes every male knows that yeah every
male i mean i've seen it twice
i'll admit i've had girlfriends i have a
wife not seen it
it's a good movie um but anyway yeah
it's a good movie i thought maybe we
should try something today i want to try
this thing where
we pull well-known movies but we only
listen to the audio
and i want to see who the biggest movie
buff is and who can
guess them the fastest guaranteed i'll
win what do i get as a prize if i win
just pride as a you know pact i am gonna
try my hardest but i'm sure i will lose
oh with that mindset rentals i have no
worries i'm gonna take first place
guaranteed
if you win quarter digital will buy you
one movie on amazon
blu-ray a blu-ray i mean if you wanna
blu-ray
download that's gonna be like i want the
criterion collection of akira kurosawa
it's not eighty dollars i already have i
already have that i
do up to up to fifteen dollars okay okay
that's it okay okay you get one amazon
buck save your private ryan
are you guys ready for some of the
finest movie clips known to man
yeah right no looking at them get out of
here
that guy i got this person to five wins
oh okay
all right ready i'm gonna keep tally
this is going to come down to
recognizing the voice of the actor
and figuring out the catalog of that
actor you might be right kenny you might
be wrong
first one you can't come back here
get the [ __ ] out of here
memorabilia we got some uh rocky
no no no no no wait wait wait wait oh oh
fiction
closet full fiction it's pulp fiction no
no dang oh you're like
that was steven seagal's 1991 out for
justice
[Laughter]
this is a mix of easy and hard ones some
are easy some are hard
ready yeah number two now look at this
nickname
okay probably should have an object
whatever
i got third one
number three go
[Music]
dark knight
sure
[Music]
it was a tough one i was surprised how
tough that was that sounds like it was
made in the 60s yeah
pick some good movies the godfather too
dude all right yeah pick some good
movies all right
i think this one's hard but i have faith
in all of you you ready
yes space balls more of the rings
the hardest
thunder
that was the trailer yeah because
there's trailers in the mood oh that's
right
do you guys want a hint before we do no
okay dude all right
all right here we go because we didn't
we didn't want it to be too easy yeah
just like randomly get a baby
[Applause]
yeah oh man that's great good job all
right
how long sticks that's tied at once
um i see how's it going nick
come over here to my cozy corner let me
turn on the fan it's a little hot
shooting a fun little video pretty soon
here um really excited about it every
once in a while we decided to shoot
something a little bit different a
little more a little weird
this fall we happen to be doing just
that in about two weeks from now we're
shooting a video tentatively called a
sam's
spooky video
[Music]
no no it's every time halloween comes
around and we're like hey we gotta shoot
something that's scary because
it's that time of the year same spooky
video
brace yourselves this is a tangent among
tangents no it's not that long hardcore
history great podcast
dan carlin's hardcore history listen to
it it's on
podcasts listening to this little one he
has called king of kings
it's all about biblical times the greeks
and the persians
fascinating stuff a couple hundred years
bc
there's a king belshazzar 539 bc
all right we're we're going way back for
this story then
what i think it's
he was at a great feast king belshazzar
surrounded by all his people
this mysterious hand of god comes down
and writes all these ancient glowing
symbols on this wall
and those glowing symbols tell him that
he's about to lose
everything he's about to lose his
kingdom he's going gonna lose a great
battle basically
the words spell doom for him this story
is actually where we get the phrase
the writing on the wall reading the
writing on the wall like the really
obvious apparent stuff that you should
take heed to
you read the writing on the wall the
point is is that this small
story was in the context of you know all
the tumultuous stuff that was happening
in these biblical times but the thing
that really stuck with me was this idea
of this ghostly hand
coming in and like scrawling something
and then disappearing and
i was like i gotta make something up
about this that's cool so we took it
from there and we made sam's spooky
video
definitely a little more of an expensive
video than what i'm used to but time to
splurge a little bit maybe on a video
make something
that's original not branded not having
in anything to do with video games
definitely a little bit of an
exercise as a filmmaker here i'm pretty
pretty excited about this
dude i'm just i'm gonna wait for the
first one
you ready okay what just keep
it's the biggest helicopter leasing
event in the western hemisphere
since 1997. anger man my mom and dad
step brothers hey yeah
here we go go where's my mom and dad
jumanji
[Music]
keep playing it keep playing the rest of
the movie
i don't know dude i know whatever this
is this is definitely
unforgivable
[Applause]
blade 2 is the best one wait that wasn't
playing two though was it was that light
two
blade one the very first time we see him
ready all right here we go guys i'm
going to recommend
to the disciplinary committee
and you be expelled good will hunting mr
simms you are a cover-up artist and you
are a buyer not a snitch
oh i know this not miracle man this is
the one where the alpha chin is a lawyer
i would
that was advocating no i know god damn
it
it's not miracle man it's where he's
blind he's a lawyer i know i don't know
that's one guy
here's charlie facing the fire george
in big daddy's pocket and what are you
doing
you're going to reward george and
destroy charlie
can you give up yeah can i look for it
or is that true
okay scent of
did you really know it no okay i've
actually never heard of them next one
uh you know from time to time did you go
to school
no i was gonna say
[Music]
hey are you how are you doing goodwill
hunting
good morning no i said that earlier i
was going to save
money for coming into the movie no
i haven't even seen that movie
i'm just guessing based on context it's
clearly some artsy fartsy classic
it's so good rc parsley how dare you
aren't you partying good hey guys i'm
here today as a scorer space guacamole
because today's sponsor is squarespace
i'm going to see how many things i can
tell you about the beauties and the
wonders of squarespace before i get
[ __ ]
squarespace has beautiful award-winning
templates that are flexible for any kind
of website
squarespace has beautiful award-winning
templates that are the best
most beautiful way to present your ideas
or your brand
to the world look out they have an
all-in-one platform so there's nothing
to install
packs or upgrade ever it's always up to
date it works on your phones
and on your computer hey and don't
forget they have award-winning 24 7
customer service
if you don't believe me just give them a
call they'll tell you where i'm gonna
pop up next
and don't forget they have a unique
domain experience that's easy to set up
so if you need a url
just go to squarespace.com get started
so whether you live in the squarespace
of being a musician a designer a
restaurant
an online store or more make your next
move with squarespace you can start your
free trial today
by going to squarespace.com corridor
crew and getting 10
off your first purchase
all right here we go a little bit more
you're just trying to save your scaly
height with tricks
uh tremors unforgiveness haven't you
noticed the pickings
slim these days sean connery the rock
just
uh where's the lost architecture
all right here we go next one you run
your mouth kind of reckless don't you
don't need to go heal and get the
[ __ ] on the double like you
forget what's that effect
310 to yuma that's a fact unforgiven oh
wow
i'm real scared damn nice you're scared
i can see that in your eyes all right go
ahead
go ahead skin it skin that smoke wagon
and see what happens
uh escape from new york ski from l.a
this semester
i'm tired of your guests going to go to
work
oh hey nothing somebody said hey
lighter okay corral really what's up
[Applause]
no i got i keep getting those movies
mixed up
i got it i got it
is that sam's first point this is his
first point
all right here we go here we go i killed
the last honorable man
spider-man one spider-man
that's not godfather is it no that's um
all right well looks like niko's the
winner then boys
[Music]
[Applause]
a scholar of cinema that's me definitely
watched all those movies that news names
are shouted out
it's not my cursory knowledge of them
from like the edges of pop culture not
that at all
very interesting very very interesting
but i feel satisfied that was a good
challenge
i was aimed for that from the start i
didn't want it to be too easy i think we
may have gotten a little too far into
the obscure
category so i'm a little sad about that
but i think there was only a couple that
wild drums i think if you guys would
like to see this as categories like
christmas movies or action movies or
sci-fi movies or movies from a certain
year who wants to watch movies let us
know
in the comments and we'll consider doing
this again that was fun
that was fun i'm down to do this again